after visiting the site of saturday's
massacre at a supermarket in a
predominantly black neighborhood of
buffalo new york joe biden spoke
specifically of the philosophy that
underpinned the gunman's rampage that
white americans are being replaced by
non-whites for political ends through
government subsidies and immigration a
view that's being expressed in the
mainstream right of u.s politics i call
on all americans to reject the lie and i
condemn those
who spread the lie for power political
gain
and for profit
that's what it is
as for solutions biden focused on two
areas there are certain things we can do
we can keep assault weapons off our
streets
we've done it before
i did it when he passed the crime bill
last time and violence went down
shootings went down
you can't prevent people from being
radicalized to violence
but we can't address the relentless
exploitation of the internet to recruit
and mobilize terrorism
we just need to have the courage to do
that to stand up
the mayor of buffalo said he appreciated
the president's visit the number of
flowers candles and other items that
were there
show
the tremendous impact that this horrible
act has had on the community uh saw a
real resolve in the president
to make a difference uh to try to bring
to an end mass shootings in in this
country but even biden himself admits
he's very unlikely to get an assault
weapons ban passed in congress and from
left to right there's suspicion of any
attempt by the government to regulate
constitutionally protected free speech
yes civil libertarians say you could
begin fighting white supremacists but in
the end the government could attempt to
ban anyone it feels is an enemy
the shooting has highlighted the
socio-economic foundations of american
racism unlike so many african-american
communities at least this neighborhood
had a supermarket now it's closed with
residents relying on food banks it was
putting all that focus downtown
rebuilding downtown but in the meanwhile
we suffering we always been suffering on
the east side and further down the east
side
but now east side is now was winning
we got your attention
retired now enough is enough change got
to come
amen
[Music]
the conversation here is whether the
sudden focus on this african-american
community will improve the lives of
people here or is this shooting just the
latest manifestation of racism in the us
shia britancy al jazeera buffalo new
york